was hast du für schüler ich war ein sehr
guter schüler natürlich was beliebt was
geht jetzt zu sie als eingemachte
also unsere fans haben ja darum gebeten
dass wir ein thema besprechen was
vorgegeben ist nämlich als stichwort
klassiker wir sind natürlich begeistert
darauf angesprungen weil wir große fans
sind von madame bovary ich liebe madame
bovary das leseerlebnis ist ganz modern
wirklich atemberaubend wie eine
filmkamera die sich ihren weg sucht
durch die geschichte der aspekt der
zeitlosigkeit es sind konflikte und
charaktere die typen verkörpern im sinne
der identifikationsmöglichkeiten und das
ist die mixtur die dann dafür sorgt dass
etwas immer wieder gelesen wird das ist
für mich wirklich ein buch ich sagen ist
es sollte man gelesen haben worum geht
es überhaupt eine madame bovary die
bauerstochter emma heiratet einen
landarzt sie langweilig furchtbaren
nimmt sich zwei liebhaber
sie wird kaufsüchtig und am ende ist
bringt sie sich um das lesen von
literatur kann verheerende auswirkungen
haben und das hier ist perfiderweise ja
auch ein buch darüber welchen schaden
lektüre anrichten kann weil madame
bovary liest herzens romane und anhand
dieser lektüre malt sie sich ein bild
aus von einer welt in der sie gerne
existieren würde das geht wirklich sehr
tief in die menschlichen abgründe hinein
ich glaube in der pubertät ist man noch
nicht empfänglich genug für die
komplexität der meisten klasse kg ich
kenne ich würde wirklich widersprechen
und sagen ein wichtiger auftrag der
bildung ist gerade dass man bestimmte
klassiker mal präsentiert und das kennen
lernt ich habe madame bovary mit anfang
zwanzig gelesen und das ist eins von
diesen klassiker leseerlebnisse wo ich
einfach wusste das ist jetzt wirklich
großartige literatur
ich habe auch julius cäsar guernica
stimmzettel in der ecke
ende